Imagine now that we want to try and implement
some of these monadic operations, like adding
a constant to every pixel, or to multiply
every pixel by a constant.
One way to do this would be to write some
code with some nested loops that step through
every element in the matrix and performs the
monadic operation on them.
In MATLAB there is an easy way to do it and
it is a technique in MATLAB that is referred
to as vectorization.
Consider that we have a matrix with n rows
and m columns and we have a scalar.
And in in the middle we have a number of standard
arithmetic operators; plus, minus, times,
divide and so on.
If, for instance, we use the addition operator—plus
symbol—and we add the matrix to a scalar,
the result will be a matrix.
And what MATLAB is going to do is to add the
scalar to every individual element of the
input matrix and assign it to the corresponding
element in the output matrix.
So we do not have to write loops to go through
and add the scalar to every element of the
input matrix.
MATLAB will do it for us, and we use the short
hand notation of a matrix operator and a scalar.
So we can add a constant to every element
matrix, subtract the constant; multiply; divide;
raise every element to a power; and so on.
We are going to demonstrate this now with
a real example.
We will start by creating a matrix and call
it m, and its elements will all be integers,
integers between 1 and 10.
And the matrix will be 4 by 4.
We are going to use MATLAB’s built in randi
function to create this matrix with random
integer elements in it.
Now I am going to add 1 to that matrix, or
adding a matrix—four by four matrix—to
a scalar, and what MATLAB is going to do is
add 1 to every element of the matrix.
Similarly, if I multiply the matrix by 2,
we will see that every individual element
in the matrix m has been multiplied by 2.
We can perform more complex mathematical functions
in a similar way.
We can compute the square root of m, and what
MATLAB is going to do is to compute the square
root of every element within the matrix.
Finally, we can raise each element of the
matrix to the power of two, we use the operator
.^ and what we see here is that every element
in the matrix m has been squared.
Important to note that this is very different
to writing this, and what this has done is
to multiply the matrix m by itself; it is
the same as writing that.
This is multiplying a matrix by a matrix,
using matrix multiplication rules—very different
to raising each element of the matrix to the
power of 2.